chrome plug-ins and i'm like well this
company duolingo is very successful it's
a
five billion dollar company i think um i
i've been thinking about chrome plug-ins
what i think is like do two things one
look at successful companies already
that do over 100 million in sales
and just say well how can i just create
this in the form of a google plugin
or two which behaviors do people want
but they don't do it because there's a
little bit of friction and how can i use
this plug-in to alleviate that friction
right now there's a ton of downside with
google plugins you know you're
a google plugin so google can ruin you
but
it's incredibly incredibly incredibly
interesting to me and that's what i
wanted to bring up was
some google plug-in stuff and so
basically what this
i don't know if this is how she did it
but she basically um
uh or the way that i look at it is you
just look at what is
what what behaviors are people already
doing so for example
learning a language people already want
to learn a language you just change
the text of the article to a different
language or at least parts of it
grammarly did this with grammar so you
just fix it as you write
one that i use all the time is similar
web so it tells me the traffic of
someone's website
passwords you use passwords on a regular
basis so a plug-in just inserts
different passwords and loom is another
one
have you heard of loom oh yeah my buddy
was with the guy who started it
isn't that worth like a billion dollars
uh not yet but getting close it's
several hundred millions i think it was
the last round and all it
does is uh screen
record recordings yeah so so they
basically say oh you want to show
something on your screen here's a
click boom record share um
so the two famous ones that everybody
kind of has heard about is honey because
honey sold to paypal for
several four billion four billion
dollars so honey had i think 17 million
users when they sold
and what honey does is if you're about
to go check out on some website
honey will go in the background it's
looking for is there is there a deal on
this
is there a coupon for this or a sale for
this somewhere else or a coupon you can
use right now
and it's surface is a discount okay that
makes total sense i don't have to
take an action i have to remember to go
look for a coupon it's just gonna do it
and
the honey sign just glows whenever it
has a discount available
for you so that was one grammarly was
another that i think shocks people
because grammarly does over 100 million
dollars a year
so the grammarly founder spoke at
hustlecon
and he's an engineer he's like a very um
by the book
like straight shooter engineer he's
really cool his name's max
and i was like shooting the with
him and i was like dude
a freaking plug-in who would have
thought and he kind of had like a funny
eating grin on and i was like
how big are you guys he was like we do
over 100 million dollars a year in sales
and i was like would you ever believe it
he was like
yeah i thought it could be done and then
and then i go you just raise money
he goes yeah we raised 100 million the
other day i go why he goes
because it was at a one north of a
billion dollar valuation
yeah i was like oh my god you pulled it
off yeah they did it exactly
um so those are like the big successors
but there are some other ones right so
we have
pinterest was started as i believe a
chrome chrome extension so
it was uh the pin the pin button that
basically was able to
get all the content for pinterest to be
a cool app uh
you needed a quick way to pin while you
were surfing the web so that was one
and then there's others that like like
for example if i look at the plugins
that i have installed i have adblock
or you know you block origin or whatever
um that's definitely one of them
and so i think i think this was one of
those non-obvious
ideas because it kind of feels like not
a serious company
it's like dude you're just making this
like plug-in and definitely there's a
lot of people like my mom doesn't know
what chrome extensions are she doesn't
know there's a chrome extension store
she doesn't really know how to install
them like she knows apps but she doesn't
know chromic stuff so you're going to
get
a little bit more of a tech savvy
audience you know it's a smaller market
overall
but the first one is a big deal i
actually want to change your opinion of
that so i went and
looked at the numbers there's 1.6
billion
iphone users okay 1.6 billion users
2 million iphone apps in the store right
now
chrome users 3 billion chrome users
200 000 plugins there's a ton of
opportunity here i hear you that like
your mom doesn't know how to do this
but does your mom if she saw a
commercial on tv for grammarly i bet you
she would know what to do you just go to
grammarly.com
actually she doesn't grammarly because
of that she saw it and she's
self-conscious about her english because
she learned english later in life
and she like doesn't want to write
something stupid so she downloaded
grambly for that reason actually
and so that's why when i saw this toucan
thing i was like oh you guys just run a
commercial for this on tv
that's easy you're going to get so many
users and the
the plug-in the reason why the plug-ins
are interesting to me is the churn
is so low churn on plug-ins are so low
compared to iphone apps or
and we've been so we both have plug-ins
you have a plug-in for the hustle i have
a plug-in
for my my one big thing framework of
just like what's the turn on
one there's like no churn on it do we
have like thousands of users now
the engagement's not super high like
they don't always use the thing
uh but they leave it installed and
it's like you know so so we've both
dabbled in this not seriously i would
say neither of us took it super
seriously
but we were interested enough for both
of us to build a chrome extension and
get it out there to you know
five ten thousand people it's
interesting and i think that uh
um i just think that people discount it
and i think that it's far
more it's far more interesting than
most people realize and so i actually
had a brave pull some of the biggest
uh plugins so it's uh block ad block
plus adobe acrobat what do you use adobe
acrobat for
i don't know probably like flash or
something i don't know um
safe price which is a deal thing video
conferencing from uh cisco
google translate which is kind of an
indicator about for toucan which is
interesting
honey pinterest say button skype what's
uh tamper monkey
uh i don't know it looks like it's
trying to keep you safe dude there was a
cool one called ghostery back in the day
that would just show you
who who's trying to track you on every
website you go to that was kind of cool
and try to shut that down uh there's
also these paid ones so are there
was there anything interested in the
paid group no but tell me about the ones
that you've invested in because they're
actually
similar because i and so in this
document that we have i said
screenshots would be great and you said
oh i invested in this thing called
bubbles which i remember you telling me
about it but what is that
bubbles is a lot like loom which we
talked about earlier so the idea is
how do you easily share what's on your
screen with your co-worker who wants to
see it and be able
and so how do you do that some people
just take a screenshot right they use
the hotkey on their keyboard they take a
screenshot and it goes into their
desktop file
then they have to go grab that then they
drag and drop that to their friend
and then the friend has to comment on it
but they can't comment on it they have
to like
send it back as another file it's kind
of annoying right so what bubbles does
is much simpler it says
it's a little chrome extension and on
any page you go to you can say
i want to record a screen recording like
a video i want to take a screenshot or
my favorite one is a scroll
screenshot so like you know when you're
on a website that like is long
and you want to take screenshots of the
website you have to take like eight
screenshots and then send them as
separate files to somebody yeah it's a
pain
with this it just takes one long
screenshot and sends it to the person so
it's it's easy to capture the what's on
your screen
you can then comment like bubbles so
it's like a speech bubble so you just
click anywhere where you want to point
something out on the screen like let's
say
for the hustle you want to make the
trends website better you would
click bubbles you would record a
screenshot you would tap on the part of
the screen where you're like
this thing is stupid we need to change
this and you would write this thing at
stupidity changes and then that's a
the whole file is a link you just share
a link with somebody else and they can
comment back like a google doc
and so is it doing well yeah it's doing
well it's doing well specifically
actually
i think the niche initial niche that
they've done well with is agencies
and so agencies like creative agencies
there's always creative people
within the team that are sending ideas
mock-ups concepts
back and forth with each other and then
they have to share with the client also
and the client has to give feedback
so there's a lot of showing screen stuff
and commenting back and forth on it and
so that's where they're getting an
initial foothold and i think it'll kind
of
break out from there so it's like loom
but it does more than what loom does
and what's dashworks so dashworks is a
company investment that
is it's like the homepage for your
company
so this is this is a chrome extension
that's sold to companies
so let's say somebody joins the hustle
you give them their laptop
if you work with dashworks when they
when they open up their google chrome
for the first time to use the internet
they would not just see like the generic
google like new tab
page they would see like the hustle's
branded page and that page can do three
things
one there's a search bar and you could
type in anything into that search bar
and it'll find the file inside your
company
so like most companies now use slack and
google drive and dropbox and
asana and github and like all these
different tools that are all in the
cloud
so like if you've ever been on your
macbook and you want to find a file you
just use like
the little spotlight search finder right
you just type it into spotlight it finds
the file on your computer
but the thing is now with the cloud none
of the files you need are on your
computer they're all in the cloud
so this is basically that search bar for
all your cloud apps
so now so what it does is it helps any
any employee find any file that's in
your network without knowing where to go
to find it
right it's just like networking yeah
this is cool so then the second thing
you could do is you could search
anyone's name so i could be like oh what
does
steph smith do with the hustle i type
steph it'll show me her profile show me
what she does who she reports to and
that sort of thing
and then the last thing is that um you
as the kind of ceo
or your kind of your your admin at the
company
can post announcements or updates that
will show up in their chrome
like new tab bar so you can be like oh
welcome these new employees or like
happy birthday to this person
or hey remember this friday we're all
doing you know happy hour or whatever
and so it's a kind of a communication
pipe also so that i that i thought was
cool they're taking the chrome extension
to deliver critical internal company
stuff
a search for people search for files and
and internal announcements
so um this this is interesting and
another one i actually don't know how to
say this company but you wrote it in
here
how do you pronounce that luster uh jack
our friend jack
was one of the early users and i think
invested in it and he says that it's
awesome but basically they
look at wire cutter amazon
and dozens and dozens of other sources
and anytime you have a product in front
of you
it tells you the average review um kind
of interesting
i don't know how i think it's a little
better than that i think what they do is
you say yourself yeah my description was
about a year ago
you you i think what it does is you go
on amazon or whatever and you search for
flat screen tv
and uh you know it's there's so many
products out there
and all of them you know great it's four
stars what
what do i make of that um and so what
lustre does is try to make the buying
process simpler so it'll basically say
here's the recommended option for what
you searched for is the mo
this rrai has searched all the reviews
all the different websites
has all this data to tell us that this
is the most popular result for what
you're looking for
and then here's the high-end version of
it and here's maybe the low-end version
of it
um and so i don't know if the product
has evolved too much since then but
that's what it kind of did at that time
was it would help you figure out which
product should you actually buy using
data
and again you didn't have to remember to
go to luster it was a chrome extension
so you're just on any website shopping
you can go to walmart
go to amazon you go bestbuy.com wherever
you're searching
and luster will be like hey here's the
product we recommend and here's why
here's what the reviews say about it
summarized automatically for you which i
thought was pretty cool
i think that that's a this could be a
good product when he pitched it to me
and when jack told me about it i was
like this is stupid i'm not in uh
i understand though i actually i think i
i was wrong about it it's really cool
um yeah so the founders was really smart
and and
um for this one he showed me a chart uh
a graph that was doing pretty well
so here's some other ideas of things so
those are ideas that we've either
invested in or seen
i have a couple more for you so let's
use your framework of
take a popular app like duolingo that
shows that there's a need or a demand
people want to learn a language and you
make it a chrome extension as the user
experience instead of a mobile app
so or at least one of the main widgets
or main points of distribution
right so let's take meditation right you
have headspace you have calm
um why don't you have a chrome extension
a chrome plug-in that will basically say
it'll see
you know you've been on you've been
browsing for two hours straight you've
had you have 85 tabs open
hey let's take a minute would you like
to earn some earn some mindfulness
points
and take one minute quick meditation and
it just you tap the thing
it turns on there's a clock and there's
like a guided voice that's doing a
guided meditation for you
i think so i think i think meditation
delivered through a chrome extension
could work because it's so popular as a
mobile app but again for mobile app you
have to remember
to go do it whereas this could just kind
of like as you go it could pause you
and uh and help you out that's great i
think that has
that has legs uh i'll i'll i'll keep
going with this game
um do you know the you know how do you
on your iphone what's that thing called
where it blocks you from using a website
after a certain amount of time
oh yeah like time something i don't know
i don't know what you do
i never use that no do you yeah i
mean i have it installed screen time
screen time um i used to have this
chrome plug-in
called nukem i think it was called
newcomb or the option was called newcomb
where after a certain amount of time you
would nuke your website and you cannot
go
to certain websites so you could only go
to like google docs
email and that was it uh i loved it
so similar to meditation i would 100 try
to create
more of a of of these uh
what do you call this uh change your
stop using stuff app
right right right yes defend yourself
against yourself
okay i have a smart idea and i have a
gimmick idea which one you want okay
smart one or the gimmick one smart one
first all right smart one first okay we
had the founder of
you mentioned the founder of superhuman
he's the guy who built rapportive before
that
we both loved rapportive it doesn't
exist now so some people might not know
what it is but
what reported was doing was when you
were emailing somebody as soon as you
typed in their name or their email
a little sidebar would pop out of your
email that would just show you their
face
show you their name show you the last
few tweets it was like
at the time it was like magic we were
like how on earth do they know all this
it was
it just makes you a more thoughtful
person because you can see the person
you can see what they're up to
you can click their linkedin and get a
little more information and it kind of
did
like it served it up it was like you had
an amazing assistant
executive assistant who was like you
know by the way sir you need to know
this about this person
so i think you could take rapportive all
around the web so i think you could make
it where
anytime it sees a name on a web page it
just highlights it yellow
and then if you just hover over that
it'll just tell you something about that
person so i think you could
bring this idea of like anytime you see
a name
tell me a little bit more about that
person i could think you could turn that
into a chrome extension rather than
something that was just for email
how would you make money off of it um
ads boom that's my easy answer i don't
know oh all right
okay but here's my gimmick one which
definitely needs ads
so uh i think there should be a chrome
extension
let me take that back i don't think this
should exist i think this would be funny
if somebody tried to do this
um so if you ever remember million
dollar homepage it was kind of this cool
idea of like
here's a web website there's a million
pixels on the page buy a buy pixel and
sponsor it okay that's cool
i have i've always thought about similar
ideas how could you make a million bucks
of something simple and goofy and
there's this
concept in in the bitcoin world of i
think it's called a fountain or a tap
it's basically a website where you go to
and then sometimes there's like a thing
about like a spout like a fountain
and uh sometimes bitcoin free bitcoin
comes out and so a bunch of people like
to go to these to
so some projects use these to say like
go collect your coin for my new coin go
there and get some
and you would go to the website you like
collect some of the new coin that you
can get
and then other people have done this be
like hey sometimes something comes out
sometimes it doesn't it's a game of
chance
it's like a um what do they call this
they call it a um there's this company
that did this with candles we talked
about them it was called like diamond
candles i think
and at the bottom of every single candle
we're talking candles like a wax candle
that you burn
in your bathtub or whatever like like
cool candles
that's the only way i'd want to
use candles is what i'm saying
i like you start dropping f bombs to
like get masculine real quick while
talking about bathtub candles
yeah i gotta dude i use my my
bath bombs or what are they called uh
yeah
anyway i've got all of them i'm i'm a
sensitive guy man
and anyway uh they at like one in ten
thousand candles probably has a one
thousand dollar diamond
right the rest have like nothing right
something but like a like a like a
cracker
cracker jack ring and what you could do
with this
is you could always have coupons or
discounts off of something
and if you redeem them you get the
chrome extension gets a kickback
but every once in a while one out of x
does get a bitcoin
right yeah so something like that where
basically every time you open a new tab
there's a little
little package in the middle of the
screen you give it a quick click
and then you're either gonna get nothing
you get air you get
you know a tiny little something it's
like a puzzle piece or you know maybe
like a little
something i don't know something or you
can actually get some bitcoin you can
get you can get a little satoshi's
basically
and so it would just become this little
like the little hamster game where
every time you open a new tab are you
really going to not click the thing
and um and so i think you could get a
lot of people to install this to try to
get free bitcoin while they just browse
the internet
every time they open a new tab it's like
a little mini scratch off lotto ticket
that they get to
scratch off that might have some crypto
inside and um
you could give away little coins
you could give away micro
amounts of bitcoin you can give away
little puzzle pieces and if you get it
right it's like the monopoly game at
mcdonald's
we actually earned the bitcoin if you
get all the pieces you can make a game
out of it basically
and uh and then the rest of the screen
you just plaster with ads
or sometimes what comes out of the box
is just an ad and uh i think that's how
you make money
off of my gimmick chrome extension well
i hope someone tries this because i
think it would be hilarious that they
create a product out of your joke
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road less travel never looking back